raise your right hand I will begin by
swearing you in the day's testimony
began with a warning from the former
White House policy expert on Russia and
Ukraine some of you on this committee
appear to believe that Russia and its
security services did not conduct a
campaign against our country and that
perhaps somehow for some reason Ukraine
did this is a fictional narrative that
has been perpetrated and propagated by
the Russian security services themselves
the owner Hill testified Russia was
watching the impeachment hearings and
ultimately would benefit from
Republicans repeating the quote fictions
that Ukraine meddled in the 2016
elections with the help of Democrats she
said she had warned Gordon Sandlin the
EU ambassador the same when she realized
he was carrying out the president's
personal political agenda by requesting
Ukraine open investigations into Trump's
political rivals and I did set him
ambassador Sunderland Gordon I think
this is all going to blow up and here we
are David Holmes a foreign service
officer in the Kiev embassy testified
Ukraine has been cleaning up corruption
under its new president below to mere
szalinski home said szalinski wanted an
oval office meeting with Trump but it
was made clear that Solinsky wouldn't
get the meeting unless he announced on
CNN that Ukraine was investigating Joe
Biden this was a demand that President
zelanski personally commit on a cable
news channel to a specific investigation
a president Trump's political rival
Holmes testified he also had a clear
impression that a hold on US military
aid was likely intended by Trump to
pressure Ukraine for the investigation
Holmes said he overheard a phone call
between Trump and ambassador Shawne
'land discussing whether szalinski would
cooperate
so you heard president Trump ask
ambassador Sandlin is he going to do the
investigation yes sir what was
ambassador soglin's response he said oh
yeah he's gonna do it he'll do anything
you ask that earned Holmes this rebuke
from Republican congressman Mike Turner
your statements that your interests are
protecting Ukraine are very dubious when
you embarrass president szalinski by
making those statements you didn't have
to make who cares that ambassador
Sutherland said that who cares that
question sums up a Republican defense
strategy to counter these five days of
public testimony that Democrats say show
Trump at best misused his office and at
worst committed bribery but is that
enough to move the American public the
latest polls show that Americans remain
evenly divided on whether to impeach
Trump and remove him from office and the
vast majority say that these hearings
will not change their minds Heidi Joe
Castro al Jazeera Washington well Brett
Bruin was a director of global
engagement in the White House under
President Obama he believes the
Republicans are starting to change their
approach to the inquiry what they've
been trying is just to throw everything
up against a wall and see what sticks
the problem is they're losing ground
they are this defensive position has
significantly retreated since last week
when these hearings began at first it
was well they didn't hear directly from
the president then it was well yes
ambassador sunland's saying it was a
quid pro quo but did the president
actually ever use that term and when you
are moving your defensive position you
are certainly in a weak position I think
that the real question now is whether or
not we will see some of these Fox News
observers from the conservative Channel
here in the u.s. start to entertain the
idea that maybe the president did
something wrong which will give
political cover to those Republican
senators who will ultimately have to
vote to remove the president